yo guys what's up its procedure mad weed
some more borderlands pre-sequel content
now today we're gonna be talking about
us some dialogue that you're gonna see
here played and you might hear it a
little bit if I sound on that talks
about the next dlc character as well as
possibly Borderlands 3 next possible
installment in the borderlands series so
once you go into ultimate vault hunter
mode and you go into the hollow dome
your Axton and gage will start talking
again and I believe that only in
ultimate vault hunter mode is when you
get this certain dialogues and I've
played the hollow dome in true vault
hunter mode I didn't get this dialogue
so accident and gage I think that was it
um for the new dialogue they start
talking about how they had to bring back
this chick named orillia and who is a
very not kind person you don't want to
meet her and how she's a vault hunter
and they just got back from the other
vault and how Wars coming so this is
some interesting stuff because if you do
not know i'd make a video about it but
if you do not know oh really uh the
bareness is confirmed as the next
borderlands dlc the the net last
character dlc coming out of Borderlands
the pre-sequel and she's gonna be like
kind of cryo based and sniper and I
believe she's uh she's sir hammerlock's
sister and she's very not nice but with
this stuff talks about it highlights
obviously just more confirmation that
the bareness will be orillia will be the
next and last dlc character these are
still are getting a story dlc and that
this is I in my opinion more
confirmation about borland 3 because
that means that her dlc character is
gonna have to do with other vaults and
about the upcoming war oh it's art it is
semi spoil spoilers if you hadn't be in
the game however I'm assuming all of you
guys have be in the game at least one
playthrough
so there isn't much more hard content
than that it's mom come to speculation
on my side but I do think that and I am
happy about the next DLC or I don't may
I assume it's next before the story DLC
that the Orillia DLC is going to be
talking about the other vaults a little
bits and possibly i had about the war
that's coming up for all the vault
hunters are gonna fight have to fight in
and how it's possibly maybe talking
about what will it be having in
Borderlands three and however that is
just my opinion they could kind of just
ignore that I think it'd be kind of
stupid if they ignore that but they
might just ignore that like they I don't
think they put that quote at the
dialogue in this game if they didn't in
this a hollow dome scene if they didn't
be important to be like it so you guys
hope you've enjoyed this quick little
video just make sure you call that a
content again and make sure like if you
thought you heard something about it
really and you kind of deserve it out
you this is confirmation you give you
something about really in this holiday
DLC so you guys hope you enjoyed this
video be sure to check out my channel
for more Borderlands the pre-sequel
content and I'll see you all later he's
up